good morning millennials happy um happy
what monday
if there ever was a monday this ain't a
monday and i don't know what is
hey guys welcome to florida well if
you're listening as a podcast business
as usual premium audio quality yeah yeah
brazen's dress brass is here missing
straps but he's just down the street he
should have been here but the couch
ain't big enough for the four of us but
for the 11 people who watch us on
youtube we have decided to build an
extremely impromptu this is not we
repeat not jackie's official home studio
setup we just got some [ __ ] off of
amazon we had a random couch laying
around i just ran to best buy if i'm
looking a little shiny it's because best
buy is hell on [ __ ] earth and i
bought us a new fancy camera so we're
doing the most let's see from the
beginning so today is monday yes last
time we saw you guys it was wednesday
and if these haven't been the four
craziest busiest days of life i don't
know what has been like i moved down
here my moving boxes during that time
claudia decided to take an extended trip
to florida who knows when and if she's
ever leaving which was so exciting for
me because i love you and i miss you
right you moved to florida on thursday
and i took a flight on saturday but you
planned it on friday yes yeah so i
missed you so much and i'm so excited we
had an amazing weekend which we'll get
to but it was also just great for
content because we can be together and
we get that you know that happens when
we're together right so even though
we're different in a second when we're
remote and it's like craziness it's not
a gina it's a mental illness like
we're unhinged yes but we have jackson
claude back in the studio so once we
realized that we would be podcasting
together then we were like why do audio
only we could put together a little
studio now like we need to
drive home the point that this is
temporary yeah we heard your nasty
critiques of this couch which is very
cool by the way in defense of this couch
this couch never asked to be a star
right this couch never asked to be on
the show like we said couch like you're
looking nice do you want to be on the
podcast the vodcast and the couch
acquiesced no and the couch was there
for us when nobody else was so honestly
will not tolerate any [ __ ] slander
about this couch and you guys being like
that couch is ugly that couch is not it
that couch is not toasty like we
recognize that this isn't the typical
toast we recognize that you know what is
toasty perseverance and courage
and that's what it takes an
entrepreneurial spirit coupled with
mogul energy right waking up literally
the crack of dawn to go to fedex and
best buy just so we could get a pre like
i just want to hear the critiques but
it's really important to remember like
this is not jackie's official florida
setup she has sickening wallpaper more
furniture we have a whole thing but we
figured while we were here we might as
well be moguls and video together and
honestly we did a little test shoot last
night it looked super cute obviously not
as premium as our studio in new york but
you know what it's actually pretty great
and if you want to know what the journey
was like to building this studio
we vlogged okay so i couldn't put my
finger remember during the vlog i said
this feels like we're filming an episode
of arrested development yes
somebody left a comment and i'm sorry i
don't know who it was um and that
perfectly that's i wasn't trying to say
arrested development i got the wrong tv
show it was literally an episode of the
office yeah like zooming in on people
and like their reactions right and
working with your co-workers and talking
about the experience it was so funny we
were putting together everything last
night and by putting together like you
know angles moving the couch setting up
the lights you know this art had a glass
on it that voice a glass frame the boys
took it off because there was a glare
just all this stuff and we were sitting
here we're laughing so hard and we were
filming it because it was a test and
we're like we should just be vlogging it
because we're filming ourselves anyway
and then it turned into really a
masterpiece the reviews have been so
rape people are saying it's the best
episode yet they said they haven't felt
this way since the great chili cook-off
yes i saw that as well it really is so
premium it felt like a little episode of
a reality show and it's hysterical and
really the husbands were the stars like
we're in it obviously because husbands
brothers us
yeah we were like irrelevant uglies in
that video and i wouldn't have had it
any other way
it was such a delight to film it's on
the patreon now um patreon.com the
morning toast and you can also get a
little like look-see behind the scenes
of how we came to this stylistic choice
yes given the resources that we had so i
just want to say once again this couch
is not permanent we're not trying to
make it like the new toasty thing this
couch just was wanted to be an anonymous
couch in my house and now it's thrust
into the spotlight and all the hate it's
receiving like
it doesn't deserve that this couch is a
private citizen
um but i'm i'm hoping like a um a fan
account pops up for the couch yeah just
as for this couch
it's very cool i think it's cool like
not only i wouldn't choose this couch
like for the show but like as just like
a cool piece of furniture it's cool like
you should keep it in your studio like
if you i don't know need to take a
siesta between podcast podcast podcast
meeting meeting meeting podcast podcast
vodcast photoshoot photoshoot photo
shoot so
now that the four people who actually
tune in on youtube have been addressed
let's address the millions who listen as
a podcast yes hey guys hi
um let's catch up like you literally
have had a life-changing week and
obviously i had to you know come down
here and make it about me of course no
but i couldn't have done it without you
and the idea that i would be here and
have that experience this weekend and
you wouldn't have been there like it
wasn't meant to be that way yeah no i
completely agree yeah so you really made
this weekend so in crayon thank you it
was just a really
floridian weekend i feel like i'm
hitting the ground running living here
have you been drinking my coffee bruno
you're going to be so brutal is going to
be like zoomies all [ __ ] night as if
bruno couldn't get crazier can i ask you
a question would you ever drink that
after bruno drinks it
if i needed to but this was the end of
my second cup i could say goodbye if it
was the beginning of my horse cup bryce
we're sharing coffee right but i think
it's a no for me dog yeah you want to
get rid of it set it down yeah but don't
work the couch remember the couch of
course i'm just it's fine i'm living in
here okay yeah scary okay so it's been a
transformative weekend but
between moving like all the treachers
that come with moving and i really tried
to make it as least treacherous as
possible yet it still came for me
there's going to spill because the arm
of the couch just get up and put it on
the ledge get up get up this is
okay inhumane bruno get your butt up
here thank you
i shall let you know like this is our
first podcast of the week and so far i
wouldn't ask you to come back tomorrow
so get your [ __ ] ass up and sit down
yeah because you were being an angel
last night i'm the movie star yeah okay
so this weekend back to it right so i
got here on saturday and we had such a
fun time like we've been swimming we
went out to lunch i've been hanging out
with kayla and rolled so much did you
get what you came here for so far
i still
haven't found
what i'm looking for because i'm looking
for a pub sub um i haven't found one
i've you know i've never had a pub sub
no but everyone's saying like you would
love them no the chicken tenders are
like known there but i haven't really
even spoken about this because everyone
is so mean to me whenever like i do talk
about it but i've been like
dieting
um
and like i wanna sub so bad but i'm
really doing a good job and i'm really
proud of myself and i'm starting to feel
like so much better
um
physically emotionally mentally
spiritually so i went to publix
yesterday i bought a lottery ticket by
the way i forgot to tell you if you want
in you have to tell me because the
numbers come out tomorrow and currently
it's me and the shapiro's so i could
invest in your ticket yes
i did 40 worth of the mega millions is
at 790 million dollars jax 40
and the powerball florida exclusive is i
think 103 104. so um it's very exciting
so if you want to get in you're gonna
have to ban mummy because then me and
olivia win and then we move to you know
beverly hills right and we leave you in
the dust damn okay how much of an
investment are we talking well do you
want in on the mega millions and the
powerball or just the mega millions
which is 790 i think just the powerball
so that would be uh what is 40 divided
by 3 15. it's like odd 11
12. this is sad
it's 13 and 33 cents yeah so
i actually gave me a deal 13
call it even well then we would split if
we win we'd split it proportionally got
it so i'd be like 32 and and
two just lose a couple million dollars
because you wouldn't send me 33 cents
okay so it was very exciting and you
know i buy lottery tickets all the time
but
i don't know how the lottery works i
just know if you live in new york like
you don't win yeah always someone in
florida hello why not you
why now it's gonna be me i love this
encouragement actually i feel like this
happens once a year on the show we're
wearing a powerball wii you
buy a lottery ticket and you are a
personality trainer no you're on this
high horse of like you're winning the
lottery everyone else is being left in
the dust if you don't buy a lottery
ticket this is your last week as a lay
person jackie if you don't buy a lottery
ticket and spend the time until you find
out you lose like acting as if you're
gonna win hands down no question then
you're not a human being everybody buys
a lottery ticket and spends the next
couple days like basically just assuming
they're gonna win i think that's the
problem though and that's where people
get into trouble because people who buy
a lottery ticket every week and live
that week like they're about to win the
lottery can find themselves in a lot of
debt okay that's true but i was talking
about this with olivia because i spent
60 on tickets like i got a lot of
numbers which is really dumb because
they're literally two dollars but then i
was saying to olivia like olivia was
saying you know sixty dollars basically
down the drain because you're not gonna
win i'm like yes but the excitement i'll
feel for the next three days like
talking about it looking podcasting i'm
making my money back right now you know
that's worth 60 dollars to me three days
of joy for 60 as long as you're not
living large
and spending money that you haven't
earned or won yet no i'm not i'm i
didn't mean uh financially i heard you
at best buy this morning were spotted at
best buy like buying up all the
equipment
i bought literally three things and that
was all i had in the store you know the
supply chain has hit best buy i was
talking to the man who works there
anthony literally such a nice guy and
can i just say how i hate buying
podcasting equipment because somebody
always asks of course and then you also
not only do not want to like talk about
yourself because you're so shy no it's
awkward but then you also do sound like
a person who's in their basement like
thinking that the world cares what you
have to say so and then also it's like
well i'm about to be a podcaster and if
your personality isn't dazzling while
you're talking to them it's like why are
you podcasting i was being quite
dazzling but it did occur to me that
this man thought i was just gonna like
literally like open up my computer and
like think i'm gonna be the next morning
toast
um so i felt like slightly thought you
were gonna be the next claudia ashrae
right i was slightly embarrassed but i
also didn't want him to like press
because like then he googles and it's
just a downhill like i just i prefer to
buy my podcast equipment online is what
i'm saying um and he told me the supply
chain crisis has hit best buy as well i
would imagine so literally the entire
store was so empty i'm like is this a
brand new store are you guys going out
of business he's like no the chip crisis
i'm like excuse me the chips like these
tech companies don't have a lot of chips
and everything every product needs a
chip that's what's happening with cars
too so they're not gonna put a chip in
like a hundred dollar camera because
they only have so many left they're
putting them in the three thousand
dollar cameras so that's all there is
available i was able to get a decent
price on this gorgeous canon one but
best buy is truly um
the
the worst yeah
i would feel like it would be
not the worst but i haven't graced one
in a decade so i can't say yeah and it's
just like it's crazy how if i was in the
city and this morning i had to go to
fedex because neither you nor livia have
a working printer and you have a pass
maybe because you just moved but i'm
like olivia you both work from home you
don't have a [ __ ] printer
i have a printer um complex like because
i have one and i think it's like really
irresponsible when other people don't
yeah you do have all of those things
yeah yeah um and it's so cheap and so
easy like i just i don't believe in not
having a printer so i had to go to fedex
best buy and then i was thinking like if
i was in new york like i would have
gotten the [ __ ] done in 30 minutes
everything was 45 minutes away like but
you got to drive do you listen to music
of course i was being insane i cannot
believe i didn't crash to shapiro's car
there's just a lot going on and the
yellow lights here are
insane because they're long they're so
long so you get comfortable so i'm
driving and i'm like oh maybe i'll slow
down but no like i had then i literally
almost died like i i fully around like a
complete red light and i'm like standing
in the middle of the interface i'm like
i mean the intersection yeah this is an
interface
and i'm like oh my god this is literally
like how people die and i was thinking
if i got um pulled over like i would
have a really good explanation i'm like
sir i'm incredibly confused like is the
light yellow for 30 seconds or 30
minutes i can't tell
yes but being an out of towner i do
think that's a typical excuse oh it's an
excuse people use i think it depends on
the officer and if he wants to grant you
a pass but like even though the light is
yellow for 30 seconds like you still
should have slowed down right i guess
that's that's so true you know but i
like had a heart attack i was having so
much fun like listening to like all this
country music and then like reality hit
oh my girl slow down did you get a nice
coffee that's all you needed a big
coffee no i didn't get a nice coffee i
don't want to take a dump into your car
you'd rather take one on my couch i
thought that would be rude you know
they let me borrow their car that would
be really really really rude
so how are you liking suburban living so
far aside from that no it's just like
crazy there really are so many cultural
differences between living in a city and
living in a suburb and i obviously
always knew that but to like actually
wake up and go to work in the suburbs it
was a lot of work yeah well literally i
haven't even done my job yet i'm
sweating we also are putting together a
studio for like the number one podcast
in the world soon to be the number one
podcast in the galaxy right
so i imagine you're tired it was
extremely difficult before we keep
catching up do you mind if i say
something i would love if you said
something because i think you i know
what you're going to say and it's
something that i need to say also yeah
because um
i walked into your house and i saw the
most gorgeous piece of furniture in a
bedroom that actually does not belong to
me which is super super [ __ ] up it
belongs to the counselor we're calling
it snitch's room because i have two
guest rooms and one is for claudia and
one is for snitch and the bed in
counselor's room is
um
jackie's home has been graced by a zuma
bed yes you guys and zuma is a brand
that practices an intentional less is
more designed philosophy for the bedroom
clean lines subtle curves and lifestyle
enhancing details that's us
clean lines subtle curves not so subtle
mine and lifestyle enhancing details
thuma proves that simplicity is the
truest form of sophistication
introducing the bed by thuma hand
crafted from eco-friendly high quality
upcycled wood you'll find beautiful
unique variations in the natural grain
the minimalist design featuring japanese
joinery helps elevate any space it's
super supportive for your mattress it's
breathable and made to naturally
minimize noise and create space and it's
made for how you live the bed is backed
by a lifetime warranty ships right to
your door in three easy to maneuver
boxes and we can attest to that
experience and it takes about five
minutes to assemble and you won't end up
murdering your husband so it's so good
so important zuma saving lives what's
the point of having a bed if you don't
have anyone to share it with
that should be through this tagline in
addition to zuma they also have other
essentials that elevate bedtime like the
nightstand the side table and the tray
um so create the feeling of checking
into your favorite boutique hotel suite
but at home with the bed by thuma now go
to thuma dot co co slash toast to
receive a 25 credit towards your
purchase of the bed plus free shipping
in the continental us go to thuma dot c
o slash toast that's t h u m a dot c o
slash toast for twenty five dollar
credit and get your zuma
zuma zuma zuma let me be your tuma i
just sounded like britney spears like
you didn't
good thing we're recording this yeah
because we'll play it back yeah
yeah also oh you got your hair out of
the tape did you see that my hair was
stuck in mine you taped your hair to the
card the thing is when you're a hairy
beast like me like these things don't
even faze you you find your hair
if i
when i have a child um literally i'm
gonna come to his room and like my hair
is gonna be in his mouth like my hair
everywhere no especially with the post
part i'm shutting my hair
everywhere right now it's like i go to
someone's house and i can't even like
redo my ponytail because i come out with
a bunch of a hair mess like where do i
put it um
where can i put my wig
i don't have to get up and throw it away
i wanted to say that like you've had
like a transformational like week um and
i feel like i've talked the whole time
in this catch up so can you talk but
that's how it goes and it's fine because
you're here like if you were in new york
and i was talking about my weekend
that would be i mean i wouldn't put it
back tell me about you like you have a
closet that's so big now you have a tub
like tell me the thing is everything is
great i'm just so
overwhelmed and doing so much and moving
so quickly and constantly trying to
catch up that nothing has settled in
yeah which is pretty good and i do feel
like that's also
a good coping mechanism like it doesn't
feel like a lot has changed because i
haven't processed it yeah and by the
time i do process it hopefully i'll be
settled in and i can just like skip over
the processing true true you know and by
the way if you guys wanted to see like a
peek at jackie's house you should get on
patreon because while the boys were
being busy we were like [ __ ] around
and finding out with the camera and you
had a nice little sneak peek you did of
my little upstairs area which has
actually turned into my favorite area of
the house and it's so random because
it's like work and play and lounge it's
very cozy and i intend to make it even
cozier
and other than that the only thing
that's like i mean everything is so
overwhelming but what's really putting
like the
nail in the overwhelming coffin for me
is like
pumping oh it's just like a nuisance
it's just oh my god i can't find the
time and like you just have to like sit
there and do nothing for 30 minutes i
mean
i try and like find this morning i
decided every time i pump i'm going to
use it as an opportunity to read because
i haven't been able to find enough time
to read and i want to so like maybe i
will won't dislike pumping so much if
it's my reading time that's actually
really trying to find like small joys in
it it also could be like a good time to
meditate because you have to sit there
for 20 minutes maybe a little meditation
but i do think reading i just finished
my book we've been reading all weekend
in addition to like everything else that
we're doing on our new kindles we both
have the oasis and i have to say
it's a fabulous product i'm so glad i
got it on prime day because i don't know
if i would pay i think it's like 300
something i wouldn't pay that but i got
it on prime day for a lot less and i
really like it having a button to change
the page is
life-changing i've had a backup oasis
for a year because zach got one for
himself and then he never used it so it
just became like my in case my kindle
runs out of battery kindle and that's
what happened on my flight on thursday i
we are about to take off i power up my
kindle it's dead i quickly like use my
air
what's it called hot spot to get wi-fi
to get on my new kindle to buy the book
i was reading and i got it all right
before we took off and then i was
reading on my oasis and i'm like it's
time for the change i wasn't ready
before now i'm in this period of change
and i'm ready for the kindle oasis so i
was reading the hotel nantucket by
ellen hildebrand our girl our queen
it was so good i would say it's just as
good as golden girl it's not similar at
all it's about a hotel and i liked
golden girl yeah it was just really
really good i actually wound up giving
it five stars because and i think was my
first five star fiction book of 2022.
that's that's pretty big huge that's
pretty big i um have been reading a lot
too like a lot of rom-coms like
meaningless but i've been loving them
they're so light and fun i made a tick
tock if you want to check it out um
and wait i had something really
important to say
and consuming other content because i
have finally thanks to living in the
same house as michaela i have finally
seen sing one and sing too
the like animated
it's not even a musical because it's
like no they made an excuse to repurpose
popular music and make money off the
royalty it's like kids glee honestly
yeah it's [ __ ] amazing like i have
been
loving every minute of it except some of
the voices are bothering me and i don't
really understand why tori kelly was an
elephant like her no her voice like
doesn't match the character she's like
the shy elephant yeah i think it's kind
of like she's like the bearded lady from
greatest showman it's like the same vibe
like you wouldn't expect and i just it's
just like it's but it's bothering me and
some of the animation is not my favorite
but it is just it's stellar it is a work
of art michaela loves it so much it's
non-stop like before she goes to bed and
i love it too and i've also been
learning about miss rachel do you know
miss rachel i know about her from you
you guys if you have kids you know miss
rachel and olivia introduced me to her
um she helps kids on she makes youtube
videos she makes
like helpful tutorials on word
pronunciation learning colors numbers
cute
she is so [ __ ] popular jackie she has
literally maybe
100 videos she started during the
pandemic
and they get hundreds of millions of
views because kids just watch them over
and over
and i was watching i'm like this girl's
got charisma
she has a star
she has what it takes her voice is so
cute like the kids love it and i was
thinking i'm like she just got it
started but like
people are like you have to google her
net worth it's 15 million dollars i'm
like it's not enough she's going to be
huge like for the way that the kids love
her she needs to start a podcast of
course original music she needs a line
of merchandise at walmart or like in
collaboration with target a show on
nickelodeon she's going to be huge and
she just started during the pandemic
she's going to be bigger than jojo siwa
like i just wanted to say it so that i
could say i said it so big things for
miss rachel big things for for mr h and
then there was like drama because mr
rage hasn't posted in a few months and
everyone was like hashtag what happened
to miss rage um
and then she let everyone know she's
like you guys i'm a teacher and it's a
summer and like i have offs to like back
off and so [ __ ] up her videos are like
over an hour long so kids can just like
watch and watch
and it takes a really long time to like
edit produce she has to get the licenses
to like a bunch of songs so she's just
working hard and premium content takes
time that's pretty much the moral of the
story i mean don't we know it don't we
know it i love miss rage the moral of
today's story taught me kayla so much
like obviously i haven't seen michaela
what has she taught you
she's really
like spoken to my soul in a sense that
you know like the wheels on the bus like
they do go round and round does she has
she shown you that we're all just kids
at heart
that's the thing
can you tell me i was right about us all
being kids at heart you were 100 right
and that's like when i see miss rage and
she's stick you know sticky sticky
bubble gum i'm like yes it is sticky
bubble gum no you're 100 right it's not
not sticky and if you feel like mikayla
knows all this new stuff like she's
blowing my mind like she's making knows
that bubblegum is sticky right and she's
like doing all the hand motions and
she's counting to ten and i honestly
like and this is no slight to olivia
because olivia would also say this like
it's almost rage
like olivia olivia loves miss rage it
sounds like she's fun for the whole
family and it sounds like there's just
like a lot of people who are important
to us in our lives named rage
of course parcell
miss
yeah etc etc yeah
are we all caught up i don't know what
else have you been getting into i mean
you've been with me every step of the
way i know it's been a delight it's
really hot here but it's also hot in new
york so i really can't complain yeah at
least here you can swim
have you been enjoying swimming how's
your ear you know i'm a swimmer and
obviously i was brought down with a
debilitating case of swimmers here a
couple weeks ago um and i'm not gonna
lie i did go swimming two days ago and i
got in the shower and my ear like was
kind of stinging
but it's dramatic i will not be
acknowledging nor um giving
investigating yeah i'm just
i'm just living life mm-hmm at this
point mm-hmm well i have to say pop
culture by the way like i so i was
actually going to post on my stories
today
i was recording a story being like what
do you guys want us to talk about like
and leave a box just to remind me of
like any big stories and then i didn't
like love how i looked in the video so i
exited out and then i tried to record it
again and then zach walked in and i got
angry and hello and i was like i lost my
emotion guys tensions are high like in
our family just because for the last 12
hours everyone has been helping us put
together this studio so let's just give
a major shout out to zack shapiro zach
weinred and ben's hoffer for helping us
so much and really not complaining yeah
no they did such a good job and they
were even troopers about the vlog vlog
it was so funny no but i just like i
can't talk into my phone with someone
watching me oh okay and in his defense i
was using his bathroom because mine
doesn't have mirrors yet and
um oh no like when he walks into the
room if i'm like doing content you'll
have to stop and then i lost i lost my
join mojo you know i lost my mojo but
what's big in pop culture like so it's a
lot of small stuff and we'll be talking
about it there's not like one major
thing that we've missed that's good
because like honestly i hate when we
have to take like time off and then
something [ __ ] happens even though do
you see that people think kylie's
getting married like yes is that a story
no should we talk about that how she
went out to giorgio baldi which is
becoming the hot spot for all celebs
and she was with her gal pals stas kim
the crew and everyone was wearing
different i think they were all wearing
black and she was wearing white yeah do
you think she's getting married
on its face yes but i just don't know
why she would and if she would why she
would be so out and about with like her
bride like she's secretive i don't think
she's trying to be like secretive i
think she's just like trying to live
life and like be small about it but i
just don't know why they would they're
both have huge estates they live in
california where it's like hard to get
married you separate stuff like why
would they bother i feel like
celebrities know how to get married and
protect themselves completely
financially no matter where they live i
think that's probably a huge business
there's definitely like a boilerplate
california big estate celebrity lawyers
yeah and like you love each other so
much but you still live completely
different financial lies yeah that's
true yeah oh the big news was ben and
jlo getting married did we talk about
that yes we did we didn't yeah we did oh
my god it feels like i've literally not
podcasted we're acting like it's been
six months it was four days that we
missed seven weeks
it was two episodes that we missed so
and we still did a patreon so we're not
like totally we're just different people
well you certainly are because you
literally live in a new state now but
you've spent as much time in this you've
moved just as much as i have
oh my god i'm literally more florida
than you you really are you're driving
you're going to publix yeah you're
engaging with the local
customer rep at best buy a local economy
you have a new man named anthony i'm
winning the powerball
these are like a florida icon
everything's coming up cloudy
okay i think we should jump right in
because we're about to hit uh 30 minutes
and
we have not yet spoken about and we have
a lot to do we should do the past five
it's monday so everyone has to unburden
themselves
as much as we want to talk about
ourselves like we're here to do a duty
and that's to un-their burdens that is
so true and that duty usually revolves
around duties so let's get into it and
it's not going to happen in the
shapiro's car no so without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
um and today's episode is brought to you
by all birds summer is here and that
means hotter temps and longer days it
also means more opportunities to get
outside and make the most of after work
happy hours and impromptu picnics yeah
so try the tree breezer a ready for
anything flat made
from breathable tree material it's
eucalyptus fiber is moisture wicking and
odor reducing it's perfect for hot
summer days everybody loves all birds
like i um obviously got a pair a little
while ago but before that people have
been like obsessed it's like a culture
of all birds yeah for sure the sneakers
are fabulous fabulous because they're
amazing walking sneakers but you can
also wear them to the gym and you can
throw them in the laundry machine right
but i just got their new um
flats they're like the tree breezers
and you know i love a cute flower but a
lot of my flats are not i wouldn't call
them walking flats or comfortable yeah
right but these
knock every check off the list they're
comfortable they're cute and they're
flat and they're made of sustainable
materials and the ribbed collar and
movement friendly design feels like it
was made just for you they're
lightweight they're breathable and cushy
all day the tree breezer is your secret
to a comfy summer find your perfect pair
at allbirds.com today that's a-l-l-b-i-r
dot com allbirds.com thank you all birds
for sponsoring this extremely premium
florida episode of the morning toast yes
thank you so much okay our first story
some light fare
selena gomez celebrates her 30th
birthday with her bestie taylor swift
and a lot of other celebs her party
looked poppin what are the deets on the
party because i personally only saw this
photo so um olivia rodrigo was there
billy eilish was there
um
selena's like inner circle it looked so
much fun i've been seeing so much about
it on tick tock and people were
obviously quaking that billy eilish and
olivia rodrigo were hanging out together
um why is that a big deal like just two
pop icons oh for sure i've never seen
them like hang out like selena and
taylor right no and i gotta keep an eye
out for selena the thing is i'm
constantly keeping an eye out for selena
um but the thing that broke the internet
was taylor swift like finally posting on
instagram thank you girlie of course she
posted uh 30 nerdy and worthy with a
picture of selena i have like i know i
keep saying this but it's really like a
testament to like how people can change
i have become such a big selena gomez
fan i love her makeup i love her music i
love her um acting i love her friendship
with taylor swift i love her as a
celebrity like i love her social media
content and i used to be like a major
hater and that's because i'm a negative
and like disgusting person um so i just
love this i love celina and hillary
clinton is 30. that's really a
coming-of-age disney story it is and i
think a lot of us are 30 now you know
and i think that's what that says like i
will soon be 30 but selena is reminding
me like that's what's coming for me yeah
and it actually is really nice like amid
all of the um like the disney
friendships breaking up and then like
taylor's girl squad waking breaking up
that celina and taylor have remained
tried and true
it's a statement on friendship and
females supporting females yes
which we know all about
right because we support each other when
it's convenient was there anyone who
should have been there that wasn't there
what are the talkers saying people
aren't really speculating on any feuds
um it just looked like a really fun
party and selena looked beautiful and
like she doesn't really hang out with a
ton of other celebrities she has like an
inner circle um so people were just
excited to see her like being out and
about girl yeah yeah which is exciting
have you watched only murder season two
yet no i do know there's a really big
plotline about a squatter so i'm like
kind of nervous because i'm convinced to
have one i'm gonna be triggering now i
hope my squatter is limited up while i'm
gone
i left drinks for him in the fridge a
nice blanket fresh towels how do you
know to him
it's a him you can feel the male energy
i heard him cough and it was definitely
a man's cough interesting yeah
um so i hope he's doing well and no
they're dropping episodes
do you think he's watching listen he's
just like a really big fan maybe he's
listening in the walls right now maybe
it's kylie if you could say something to
your squatter what would you say
hmm
that's a good question would you even
want him to leave or do you like the
company honestly if i had the
opportunity to speak to him i think i'd
politely decline like the way we kind of
live parallel lives is really poetic and
beautiful you know
yeah and are you sure it's not a ghost
because in the hotel nantucket there's a
ghost that uh i'm gonna read the book i
don't know i know she she comes out
chapter one um she's one of the
characters and it's like a cute edition
even though you would think it would be
weird and it's just making me think like
it's
what else could be haunted maybe your
apartment you did say it's pre-war it's
very old and spooky brian kelly's house
has a a ghost named gwynevere
um a previous tenant who i believe died
in the home in like the 1800s because
brian's house is like an old farmhouse
that's been around you would actually
find it interesting it reminded me of
the gilded age yes doyle's town yes you
were telling me um and gwenevere
definitely pops her head out every now
and then and it's it's actually really
spooky like you can feel gwenevere's
presents and i kind of love the name
gwenevere yeah why you should put on
your list of baby names if you're
thinking about having a girl i will put
it when my phone isn't busy doing double
duty as a backup recording just in case
this one doesn't actually work and you
need backup audio we have so much
unnecessary equipment like no because
you have so much trauma from losing
episodes if you lose an episode once
yeah you will have backup of everything
true podcasters know like always have
your voice memos be recording everything
you're doing like just in casual
the crazy thing about michaela is that
like she speaks a little spanish yeah
she's so like by lit i'm like just
living in a home with her i'm amazed
kids are amazing they really are campers
are amazing when they go from just being
like babies who need you to like do
everything for them to like
a sense of independence like she can
walk wherever she wants she can
communicate like it's really jarring
yeah but then should they just need to
reach that third level where they start
to do stuff for you so that's what i
keep saying like i definitely see um why
people want to have kids because when i
have kids and they become of the age
where they can communicate with me like
100 we're speaking like i don't know how
old that is like for
and like when you're fully able to like
speak the language i don't hold a
conversation yeah yeah have a person
yeah i don't know
um and like listen to me i will be
using my children as servants like
whatever i can like you think i don't
get up now i do i will if i'm we're
sitting right here
ready this is gonna be an example we're
sitting here podcasting 10 years from
now okay our kids are downstairs okay
joey i'm calling joey i don't know why
my kid's italian joey joey because i
need my scrunchie over there six feet
for me i will bring my child from
upstairs to go get me my scrunchie and
that's on giving them life 100
i don't make the rules hundred percent i
would say that's the one issue i have
with the streis brothers
they i don't have thumbs and they can't
[ __ ] help i keep waiting for them to
be able to listen to me understand what
i'm saying and communicate back so that
i can say
literally you can let yourself out the
doorknobs right there get on your back
two feet no if only they had thumbs i
know
but they're so darn cute they're so darn
cute
are you ready for our next story the
saga continues because adele finally
announces the rescheduled dates for her
las vegas residency las vegas she said
she's more excited than ever adele is
taking las vegas in just a few months
and attempting to remove the stain from
her reputation it's gonna be tough on
monday morning the singer announced the
reschedule dates for her long-awaited
sin city residency at caesar's palace
coliseum now set to begin in november
and run through march 2023. it is the
real caesar's palace by the way yeah
quote words can't explain how ecstatic i
am to be finally able to announce these
rescheduled shows i was truly
heartbroken to have to cancel them but
after what feels like an eternity of
figuring out logistics for the show that
i really want to deliver and knowing it
can happen i'm more excited than ever i
mean she's gonna have to uh do fireworks
because it was she needs to repel off
the building like pink right it was so
crazy they couldn't get it done
logistics they couldn't happen it needs
to be mind-blowing and not just her
performance now because you go to an
adele concert and if she had stuck with
the original date people would have had
no expectations other than adele just
being the beautiful singer that she is
now with all the attention drawn to the
actual quality of the production it has
to be larger than life it has to be the
biggest thing vegas has ever done it
needs to have a circus a pool
pyrotechnics like
i won't be satisfied and then maybe then
i will believe her yeah because not to
like doubt her um but i'm definitely
doubtful i think a lot of people are and
this is just
as we've said so many times it's a weird
story it definitely tainted a lot of
people and her for a lot of people in
their mind and
now she has to put on the show that
didn't need to be canceled because the
logistics didn't work out right so um
we'll have to wait and see again oh
we're always waiting and seeing speaking
of waiting and seeing did you make it a
story ricky martin yes okay because i
wanted to of course because it's so tiny
you can't just throw out that he like
dated his nephew and then not take it
back when the claims are dropped okay
yeah so i will get there i just wanted i
forgot to ask you that before we started
recording because i was sofa yeah no we
waited and we saw and now we see because
we waited and we saw
and that's what we got because we waited
and i love seeing once we've waited
and i also love waiting
before i see 100 right
um
so adele she's getting back out there i
think that's great
i don't think i'll be going unless i
just like happen to be in vegas i don't
think that's anything i would fly in for
i know but if i'm there that's something
i would i would totally love to see but
it sounds like a gorgeous way to like
spend the evening like put on a cocktail
dress
shake yourself a martini and go see
adele and go
easy on me baby
you're like definitely getting better
i was just a child
didn't understand
gonna get that chance too
the
[Music]
what wait it's like actually good
am i adele no
um
but that was good
i think i am no actually um i can tell
you for sure you're not
can't if you're adele you want to be
harry's mom
oh
shots fired um but that you're
definitely getting better it's probably
from spending so much time with me all
these years it's finally you know no but
as you grow your voice changes listen to
an episode from four years ago actually
don't that's actually cool that's so
true and maybe i'm just growing into a
gorgeous singer you know what's crazy
what if we grow up is getting worse
what if in four years from now like
you're the singer i have usurped you
the reality of that is not that crazy
i'm definitely my voice is getting worse
and worse as i get older um i think
probably like the best voice i ever had
was when i was like 18
and ever since then it's been like a
down what i don't think that's true when
do you think it was the best i don't
think that like you know i'm your
biggest
fan
vocally
and i think just vocally you're not my
biggest fan anyone else well i'm
speaking the vocal category i'm
definitely your biggest comedy you are
yeah even though i'm not a good comedy
supporter because i laugh silently
and that's a really big problem at live
shows people like you should be escorted
out immediately
there it is
um
there was
um etiquette styling and when i'm dying
over this
in for a podcast you guys probably think
i never laugh at claudius jokes that's
why we have to do people are always like
why don't you guys just switch to
podcasts only it's literally so much
cheaper and easier and we're like no one
will know what what jackie's ever like
truly feeling because she's a silent
laugher it's so true i just laughed
right there i just thought
you didn't hear it you need to work on
it like okay okay i'll start a fake
laugh just for like it's you're
literally your job to laugh on a
microphone
yeah i have one job literally you were
also saying something before i was it
sounded interesting
oh you're my biggest fan i'm your
biggest fan and i think your voice is as
beautiful as ever the only thing is you
could stand if you're gonna like sing on
the show which you do it's your job you
could stand to work with a vocal coach
and hone your skills
so i have to tell you i know we all know
you did it in college once and you like
didn't get much out of it but then in
hindsight you actually learned a few
things but you like didn't take it
seriously do i see that story a lot
maybe just to me personally so um every
semester at nyu for an extra two credits
oh here we go okay i would do
your coffee while we wait yeah it's over
here oh it looks watery i would do vocal
lessons um and that's how i ended up
like only having to take one class my
final semester um and they were actually
like some of the worst times in my life
i just found they were taught by grad
students who like didn't want to be
[ __ ] teaching me which i totally
understand and honestly i want to be
taught by a real teacher not a [ __ ]
grad student
um
and
it was really
honestly a waste of time oh man i've
been actually meaning to say this thank
you so much for bringing it up so on
tick tock i often i'm done with the
other nyu story by the way i don't even
care but it reminded me of like i have
like this thing for voice teachers like
i kind of [ __ ] hate them okay because
i'm on tick tock and i'm always getting
like vocal teacher reacts to amazing
ariana grande riff okay and i'm not
gonna say who this girl is honestly i
don't even know like
whatever you're about to say why do we
care right what about layperson reacts
right they're just like basically
showing you the technique like ariana's
able to do uh like a belt in her high
voice which is amazing you know i'm not
an expert but i can tell you ariana
grande is doing amazing things with her
voice so they're just explaining the
technique and basically just being like
amazing amazing so guttural like all
this [ __ ] and i see like the same woman
a lot of the times and i never really
noticed her i'm just like okay whatever
um and then a video of her singing
actually came up on my tick tock and i
was
flabbergasted like it was an atrocity
and it
you i'm like who the [ __ ] are you who
you've been all this time doesn't
surprise me those who can't do teach but
i don't like that phrase
i think only when it comes to like spec
like
i'm sure like a math teacher they want
to become a [ __ ] mathematician they
want to become a teacher because they
love kids you know and then like math
was just the area that they hated the
least right yes those who can't do teach
maybe like okay soccer coaches like they
would have loved to have been a pro
soccer player
yeah those who can't teach teach gym
that's so mean i just i take umbrage
with those who can't do teach because
that implies that like our teachers are
failures and they're not no i totally
agree with you but i do think it's like
in a specialized field in sports or like
okay maybe those who teach wood shop
wanted to be carpenters maybe you know
perhaps but i don't believe when it
comes to like educating the youth in
like regular school subjects
also justice for gym teachers because i
love gym and we had some great gym
teachers i love the crazy ass gym
teachers we had one like when we were
really little remember um in grade
school yeah
yeah it's just like a crazy actually
but that's what the kids need in gym
yeah they don't need to be handheld they
need a game of dodgeball yeah and
it needs to be
a kid eat kid world out there you know i
think our old gym teacher mr dolney from
vermont's i believe his daughters are
toasters i think i met them and what
kind of he was a hardcore gym teacher
yeah no and like he didn't [ __ ] around
and i think he had a gym teaching
assistant who was like you know would
placate to the weaker campers but he was
tough he took his job seriously and he
taught he also uh coached the boys
basketball team and they [ __ ] loved
him yeah that's a good teacher that's a
good teacher like sure anyone can be an
easy teacher who's just like yeah you
know let's watch movies all day let's be
a bad teacher but bad teacher was also a
good teacher because she was tough on
the kids and the kids need that
that basically the message is it always
comes back to that teacher
always and be tough on the kids they can
handle it yeah and they need it they
need it these kids are out of control
these kids are not okay yeah
and justice for gym teachers and good
luck to adele at her vegas residency
yeah i can't get here vocal teaching
yeah okay yeah are you ready for our
next story because kiki palmer is firing
back at a comparison to zendaya over
colorism she said i'm an incomparable
talent i agree with uh kiki palmer
doesn't appear to appreciate the recent
social media conversation comparing her
career to that of zendaya she said a
saturday tweet not she said hollywood
reporter said a saturday tweet drew
attention for claiming that a perceived
difference in mainstream popularity
between palmer who currently stars in
jordan peels nope which is like killing
at the time right now people are so
i we have to talk about this after but
like how jordan peele became like the
new m night chameleon even though m
knight is like still really big like how
he became overnight like the greatest
thriller director is so interesting so
interesting but so there's a tweet that
drew attention um that claimed that
zendaya's mainstream popularity quote is
one of the clearest examples of how
colorism plays out in hollywood the
twitter thread pointed out that kiki
palmer and zendaya are both former child
stars right but that nope is being
described in some circles as palmer's
breakout role but that would just be to
people who are unfamiliar with talent no
two uncultured circles uncultured
everyone knows her breakout role was t r
u e j a c k s o n v p anyway so kiki
then tweeted quote a great example of
colorism is to believe i can be compared
to anyone i'm the youngest talk show
host ever the first black woman to start
in her own show on nickelodeon and the
youngest and first black cinderella on
broadway i'm an incomparable talent baby
this is kiki palmer 100 agree i don't
like comparing um the comparing of two
the two of them but also i do believe
kiki palmer had like a break in her
career after true jackson which is why
it feels like maybe zendaya like
accelerated a little bit more um but i
find um kiki palmer to be like one of
the most underrated talents in america
yes hysterical she does it all she is a
singer
she's a dancer she's one of the funniest
actresses of all time she's gorgeous
like she definitely doesn't get enough
credit and i'm glad that like this nope
movie is um becoming so big because it's
exactly what she deserves but
i could go and i could literally write a
thesis on that 100 but i also think it's
just about like what you consume because
everything that kiki palmer does like i
am a big fan of i actually feel like i
might have seen more kiki palmer
projects than zendaya like she was in
screen cream she was in hustler she was
an aquila in the bee
aquila and the b plus she's like a
digital star too because she like does
comedy online and that parlayed into
a tv hosting gig yeah plus she has that
iconic thing she's two
i know what you want to say i'm sorry to
this man and you know what's so funny
you know she's talking about dick cheney
i'm sorry to this man i'm not and then
also oh oh oh i know eddie i know it
ain't the stallion
you know it's your girl oh i don't know
that one she um was
last year at the met gala the vogue
correspondent which is thank you vogue
for finally doing something in june
um
and she was hosting i think maybe their
tick tock or whatever doing interviews
with everyone and when meg the stallion
came up she's saying that and i can't
believe you don't know what that sound
it was everywhere for like three months
oh
i guess people on reels weren't using it
they were well i also don't watch reels
with sound because everyone just uses
the same like sad songs that are meant
to make a mediocre video that's
literally the point they say put this
over the last video on your camera to
make it feel like a mad yeah yeah and
i'm just like no yeah no
just the point i'm trying to drive home
here is like i [ __ ] love kiki no me
as well she also tweeted i've been a
leading lady since i was 11 years old i
have over 100 plus credits and currently
starring in an original screenplay
that's the number one film at the box
office hashtag nope i've had a blessed
career thus far i couldn't ask for more
but god continues to surprise me no
she's amazing and i hate that people are
literally saying anything about her
because i love her and she deserves more
roles that's really she's the more like
i feel like she gets a lot of
opportunities but she deserves more
more she's like a true teacher
i want more i want my dinner
i love kiki palmer she's actually we
should add her to our list of dream
guests
dream guest and eligible bachelorettes i
don't know is she single i don't keep up
with her personal life i'm really sorry
my phone is doing double duty i can't go
to my eligibles list like a a patron of
her art you know yes i don't keep up
with her personal life
just if she's in something like i want
to watch it yeah she does it for the art
yeah we love art and as patrons
patreons of the art we love that yeah
are you sweating always i'm so caliente
i'm hot but i'm not sweating it kiki
palmer would be a great podcaster 100
she's so funny and her voice is just
like
she's a great voice everything she says
is funny whether she tries to or not
because she's just like like a
physically and vocally funny person yeah
i love her yeah well she was doing talk
show host which is like you know right
what you do
before you decide to podcast you know
what you do um before your way down yes
or on your way up yeah she hosted like
one of the hours of the today show with
sarah and michael
it didn't last long but um it wasn't her
fault no i blame sarah
i'm kidding i don't even know what that
is
that's the point are you ready for our
next story yes i see your ipad and i'm
very excited to discuss oh i like
sitting close together because you can
see the ipad i know and then get all
excited before we move on like i was
able to wrap up the adele thing at the
end because i saw your ipad totally and
you have something to say before we get
into our next story that you see on the
ipad i got so invested in communicating
with my sis i literally forgot my job
i'm starving like what are you making me
after this something so delicious but
it's going to be health conscious
because i know that you're a healthful
girly which is why our next
sponsor is let me know sorry you like
you teamed me up sorry i didn't even
realize i was genuine i'm genuinely
hungry i wasn't trying to make like an
ad break i was just trying to let you
know like
after back break after we do this like
you are responsible for feeding me oh
okay
in compliance with me murdo
today's episode is brought to you by
noom when we decide to lose weight it's
usually just not about the number on the
scale whatever your reason is for
wanting to make a change new weight is
ready to help noon wade's
psychology-based approach empowers you
with the knowledge and support to build
lasting results so
nume is a
based program so if you have struggled
with losing weight whatever your reason
is to fit into genes to feel a little
bit better physically emotionally check
out noon because it's
really a different way to approach
weight loss and why i really like it is
like first of all i find it really easy
to keep track of everything i eat in a
day um and i've done stuff like that
before but i just like end up plugging
in the wrong thing it's like it's not
dynamic or the database isn't big enough
right or also like you feel like you
have to
not include certain things but like
it's not judgmental not judgmental and
they know that people are human and that
humans do
things so an active numeral loses an
average of 15 to 16 uh 15 pounds in 16
weeks and 95 of customers say that noon
weight is a good long-term solution so
they um their approach is grounded in
science they publish more than 30
peer-reviewed scientific articles that
inform users practitioners scientists
and the public about their methods and
effectiveness so stay focused on what's
important to you with new weights
psychology-based approach sign up for
your trial today at noom.com toast
that's n
o o m
dot com slash toast to sign up for your
trial today noom.com toast what do you
have to lose love it thank you so much
claudia it's a pleasure our next story
that has us all excited zac efron
returns to east high from high school
musical finally acknowledging us after
years of ignorance and it wasn't bliss
wildcats everywhere raise your hands up
in the air
cats everywhere wave your hands up in
the air
that's the way we do it let's get to it
come on everyone i have to say just
really quickly um i think perhaps my
favorite line from any
high school musical song
ever and i only recently came to this
realization when there was a trend on
tick tock of kids um filming their last
like year of high school um with the
song in the background and like doing
prom and graduation i was like actually
crying i wish the rest of my life could
feel just like a
high school musical
no i really like i want the rest of my
life to feel like a high school musical
it's like so cute it is really cute and
i get like chills when i hear that line
sorry that's beautiful well we're also
getting chills because zac efron
returned to east high from high school
musical and said don't you forget about
me with his fist up in the air and a
fist emoji and it's giving
reunion
of course that's obviously where all of
our minds go
what else could he be doing there it's
not some you don't just like past east
high salt lake high school east every
single day right and so zach has been
like you know
very not so subtly like
not ignoring the franchise but ignoring
the franchise no he's bigger and better
he didn't come back better than all of
them they did like that zoom thing which
you know what i was he's better than
zoom he was depressing so i'm glad he
wasn't there but like he's never really
embraced
the post hsm life
and everyone does vanessa hudgens
doesn't do it a lot actually tisdale
does it all the time somebody turn the
air conditioning on in here and i want
to kiss them on the mouth and then give
them fellatio okay like where did that
[ __ ] that just come from and where
has it been this whole time it's right
above us there's a vent and it just
started
i think the ac guy is here because zach
was saying he's coming today and you
just go give him a big chance getting
fellatio
when he's done
and then we'll totally understand
go give him a big kiss
on the house no
literally a percentage of our the ads
today like we're gonna give him like a
commission on this episode
it feels
like
my mood suddenly shifted i'm like why am
i feeling gloriously delightfully happy
um and that's why
wow oh my god thank you that just gave
me exactly what i needed okay heaven
heaven yeah he's been ignoring all the
losers from high school musical now
he is embracing them with open arms and
i think we're gonna get some sort of
quality
reunion yeah well people think that now
this is like a sign because why now you
know you've literally spent 15 years
ignoring everyone does this mean
something or you're just feeling
generous like seriously i think it's a
lot of things also maybe it took him 15
years to get it over vanessa i mean it's
taken me 15 years to get over them and
then just when i was over them boom
austin butler and her breakup just when
i was over them i see this picture
courtside you know back in the day
courtside the love i have in my heart
for them as a couple and like the way
they really elevated that franchise
because they were genuinely in love is
not something i take for granted
honestly like i'm extremely grateful to
them yeah me too and i'm just scrolling
through the pictures in this article and
it brings me down to a picture of
sharpay and ryan like doing their thing
do you know they have like major beef
that's and ashley yeah why i don't know
that's just what i heard recently do you
want to hear something interesting i
think they say and this is just the
rumor mail that she was just difficult
to work with she was giving sharpay oh
but how could you she was messing acting
how could he be sharpay and not start
acting like her wait i have to show you
claudia on halloween i have to tell you
something
there was like a huge um uproar on tick
tock that i think you would find
interesting because
uh austin butler obviously dated vanessa
ann vanessa and ashley tisdale a really
good friend he did an interview during
press to promote um elvis and it was
like who do you facetime the most and
he's like probably my best friend ashley
tisdale which is weird because that was
his ex-girlfriend's best friend so have
they you know maintained a friendship
has actually maintained a friendship
with both of them or did she dump
vanessa for austin the rumor that i read
and like so they used that to mean that
ashley stayed friends with austin
because like his star was rising and
like she wanted to be his friend and
that her and vanessa are less close
because of it but they're still friendly
but not as close as they once were if
that's the type of person ashley tisdale
is like that's that's literally like the
worst type of person you can be right
and that's a really bad thing to say
about someone if it's not true like if
it's not you stay friends with austin
because she's thirsty so now we just
need to know like issue friends with
vanessa until we confirm what i read
meant that said that they were friendly
but we were just saying yesterday the
new way to be enemies with someone is to
be like fake friends still yeah like
still comment on their instagram still
like everything still follow them like
usually used to be like you got into a
fight with a friend and you blocked them
and like that was that but now it's like
no the way to hate someone is to like
still follow them still support what
they do but just hate them yeah and like
it's very possible vanessa hates ashley
but doesn't want to make it a big story
so keeps liking and keeps commenting
yeah
interesting yeah um but back to zack's
post like it does it means a lot because
you know we all fell in love with him in
that one scene and then he just never
kind of looked back and you know who's
over the moon about this bart johnson
yes
guy who plays his dad bart johnson is
his name um his entire life since the
wrapping of film three has been
dedicated to being coach taylor online
in real life like
um
it's giving major loser energy for sure
but i appreciate that like he's keeping
the fantasy alive and there's something
but there's something really sweet about
it and
just wholesome yeah he's also blake
lively's brother-in-law yes his wife is
robin lively like sister which makes it
better and less sad like okay yeah
you're cosplaying online but you get to
have dinner with ryan reynolds probably
twice a year right i would say more her
and her sister are close yeah and he
seems like an affable guy and so does
ryan okay well i know ryan and blake
don't they live in canada
what do they yeah that's like a weird
thing i didn't know that i love canada
by the way that i mean that in a
negative way please keep watching the
toast
we do have a big canadian audience
we're big in canada are you ready for
the final story no i really am even
though the air is on so i'm actually
like i'm feeling better uh
literally the color has come back to my
face
i thought i was gonna literally have to
go to the hospital no you even heard me
say isn't it warm in here i like it you
don't say that i don't really complain
about the temperature and even if the
one is warm it has to be like dante's
inferno before i complain it's just so
crazy because when we podcast like in
our apartments in new york it's not
central air so it's just like a big old
humming machine and you can never
podcast with your air conditioning on if
you live in new york but like homes like
it's like not the same no it's just this
event is just giving us life and it's
not making a sound not a sound we didn't
even know it until we felt it it feels
so good and we unknowingly put this
couch right underneath the vent and i
just want to say like someone was on our
side yeah we had an angel on our
shoulder a ghost
gwenevere
our physical story is justice for ricky
martin because he's returning to the
stage after his court case was dismissed
as we reported last week um
in puerto rico there was a case filed
against him by his nephew um alleging
stalking harassment after they
terminated a relationship also it didn't
say that in the article that we first
reported it on but i believe it was his
step nephew so there was no blood which
is just it's still bad but it's a huge
difference different yes
it's it's different it's better yeah not
good but better now the case has been
dismissed and he took the stage at the
hollywood bowl in l.a good for him with
some help from the la philha
philharmonic together they delivered a
night filled with live music dance
numbers and iconic martin flavor no
honestly like good for him for getting
back out there because things like this
like
you don't really change if they can
change the perception of like like the
then you just
if you if they fester and like you don't
address it or like you take some time
off obviously because this is so
you know taxing jarring
um
it's like the thing that remains in
people's minds and what's so sad about
this is like people will read the crazy
headline but they'll never really follow
up with it unless you're toaster that's
why we're researching and we waited and
seed and that's why it's important to do
that and to course correct but something
like this is so damaging and yeah one of
those things that like people will
remember forever um not me tabula rasa
same tabular assets people who don't
keep up with pop culture they heard it
because it's so crazy and then in a few
years we're like didn't he date his
nephew and then it'll turn and be like
wasn't he with his son no exactly yeah
exactly so it's so damaging and it's
really [ __ ] up and now i'm just like
feeling like i need to be defensive of
ricky martin yeah and i am so here we
are that took a turn
didn't think i'd be saying that last
week no not at all also what's a ricky
martin song like live in la veda
her skin is the color of moga
such a good song like an insane bop yeah
insane and imagine if we had to cancel
that song
no a loss that's honestly some songs
are uncancelable and one of them and i'm
sorry to say it is ignition by r kelly i
was gonna say i believe i can fly no i
could live without that one i could live
without ignition it's still actually not
gonna suck it but um
like if i'm drunk at a club and it comes
on i'm not protesting and like being a
good person like i am breaking it down i
didn't realize he's saying ignition and
the other one i think it's world's
greatest okay that song is no and also
like the
the verse where it's like
that star up in the sky
it's so cloudy don't do it yeah i made
it
i'm the world's greatest no that's a
song that's really tough to lose and
that's what
really what struck me the most in that
lifetime documentary um
about him was people's inability to
cancel him because so many of their
weddings family reunions bar mitz like
things like that you use those songs and
so you're connected to your family and
your memories in your childhood with
that music and it's people are having a
really hard time with it yes also what
struck me from the lifetime documentary
about those songs is like especially
with i believe i can fly it had a you
know a very gospel religious religious
element to it so it was like he was
this star that song made him like godly
almost even harder to cancel yeah
no but um he got what he needed yeah we
waited and seen and we saw and justice
was served i'm still waiting and seeing
on galen i just don't feel good about
you here most recently she was moved to
a low security prison in florida where
she can do yoga all day florida yeah
that's where he was like in prison
that's where he was and
it's like the chillest prison ever
and we still we didn't find out one
[ __ ] person not a name how can she go
to jail for sex trafficking when we
don't know what happened and who was
trafficking
to whom
um that's upsetting really [ __ ]
upsetting now she's living the life of
riley down here yeah of course oh that's
disgusting yeah well i will never stop
talking about that yeah keep trying
bring it up anytime i'm always happy to
chat about it me too but we have our
duty to do because people need burdens
that need to be owned
yeah and there's probably some duty in
there as well for sure knowing you guys
um it is our monday segment knowing us
honestly it's unburden yourselves if you
do something over the weekend that
you're just like carrying around with
you that is really bringing you down
you're so embarrassed hand it to us
email us at unburdenyourselves gmail.com
and we're gonna make you feel better
about it and once you give it to us it's
gone like you can't think about it
anymore that's the rule and it's brought
to you by kitsch they say that hair care
is the new skincare but there's only one
brand that has taken it to the next
level with a cult-like following
kitchen's created game changing
essentials beauty enthusiasts swear by
from satin pillowcases to time-saving
towels kitchen's hair care doesn't stop
in the shower so whatever your budget
skin type or hair type kitch believes
that you deserve little indulgences at
affordable prices morning noon and night
so some of their best sellers include
satin pillowcases caps and eye masks
which are so good for your face the eye
masks are so good for wrinkles so are
pillows and i used to just like wake up
with my hair in a rat's nest i could get
the best blow out chris appleton could
blow out my hair on friday night
saturday morning it's like it never
happened um and that's when i switched
to a satin pillowcase i actually have
the kitchen one and it has made a world
of difference i'm still a rough sleeper
so i'm not waking up with perfect hair
of course but it is better 75 it's so
much better i prefer satin pillowcase
for my thoughts
it's so much better for your skin when
it feels so nice but also for
acne
roughness i have sensitive skin so i
need to be sleeping on like a literal
baby's bottom and that's the satin
pillowcase also they have quick um quick
dry hair towels which are so fabulous
they stay on your head so well they work
like a dream you seriously don't even
know until you try it's just a great
thing to put on your head right when
you're out of the shower because i have
such thick hair where was it we were
getting our hair done um at like 8 a.m
on some morning it was a photo shoot
yeah we did a photo shoot 8 a.m they
took my hair out of the ponytail i had
showered at 3 p.m the day before my hair
was still wet isn't that crazy damn tone
bragged sorry so kitch is offering you
30 off your entire order at my kitch.com
toast 30 off anything and everything at
my kitsch m-y
k-i-t-s-c-h dot com slash toast
my kitsch.com slash toast all right are
you ready i'm ready okay ready as i'll
ever be let's hear it what do we do
[Music]
hi love y'all i'm writing in ten bird
myself from literally three months ago
and i still cringe about it every day
flashback it's easter my husband was
visiting me in a different city that i
was traveling to for work how many years
ago sorry three months ago i'm sorry
okay so it was easter her husband was
visiting her because she was traveling
for work she's newly married and he had
gotten me two easter baskets one with
like classic reese's cadbury eggs some
slippers i don't know what i said you're
making me hungry um and the second one
the second one was filled with like
sexual items
so he had gotten sheer underwear sex
dice a raunchy card game and butt plugs
is that an easter tradition i think he
was just trying to spice up married life
you know they're separated she's working
he's trying to make a nice you know okay
um they had butt plugs that had
rhinestones on the end she just wanted
us to know that little detail
um i feel like it's gonna come in handy
yeah
we ended up stopping at his parents
house for dinner all goes well and we
head back to his truck and we begin to
back out we were quickly stopped by my
father-in-law running out to give us
something my husband had forgotten
inside he swings open the front door
immediately immediately notice the
basket looks me and my husband both in
the eyes hands us what we forgot and
shuts the door and walks back to the
house we have never discussed this ever
again i'm mortified that my
father-in-law's my bedazzled butt plug
set please help me forget this moment in
life
that's tough
so what your father-in-law knows that
his daughter-in-law loves his husband so
loves his son so much that she would put
a rhinestone up her butt like
yeah i i mean obviously it's not ideal
and you know i don't know what they're
what they are like really but i also
feel like parents in general have an
easier time with like their son
thinking about their son engaging in
such things as opposed to like a sibling
as opposed to their daughter no
you know like yes so i think being the
daughter-in-law
it's okay it's right okay you were a
son-in-law and you know your wife's dad
handled her but
that would be much worse that's actually
so true but also like i don't know it's
not that weird like parents you know
gave birth to you like they know what
happens they [ __ ] like
it's just an awkward moment but like i
don't think they'll think of you any
differently knowing that you guys like
have a healthy vibrant sex life you know
like if my
son like i found let's say my son and my
daughter-in-law are here at my house
spending the weekend and i go in to
clean because i love to clean and i find
like vibrators and ball gags i would be
like
good for them yes is there anything that
you could find like is there is there a
line
um
no honestly no i think i'm very open
like i'm an open-minded person
like
i don't know i don't know a lot of sex
toys i'm like trying to think like anal
beads i would be like okay maybe you
know not for me but good for them yeah i
really like i'm really not a judgmental
person so i guess the question here is
like what are your in-laws like are they
judgmental right and she i feel like she
was in there can you say again just
sexual things sheer underwear cute sex
dice a card
it doesn't like the butt plug is the
crazy one but it's really not that bad
but it was bedazzled that could be you
know like people have bedazzled [ __ ] all
the time yeah and maybe it was a wine
stopper
100 and the rest of the stuff is like
cute and flirty and fun and you're
married so like it's not like you're
using this with a hooker totally don't
[ __ ] don't sweat it it's really not a
big deal honestly it sounds like cute
and funny yeah enjoy the reese's hey
jackson claude hey i have to unburden
myself about something i did at work i'm
an icu nurse
i already see like the words down below
and it's it's made for me i'm an icu
nurse and last night at work a co-worker
and wait sorry
last night at work a coworker and i
needed to call someone to ask for help
okay the co-worker who we were calling
is named tarek and we couldn't remember
his last name that we needed to call him
on the special hospital phone i fully
said oh i remember it's el moussa
needless to say that the hgtv house
clipper turned reality star love rhombus
member was unable to be reached using
the hospital phone and my co-worker was
so confused and concerned with how i
came up with the name tarek el moussa
i'm going to chalk it up to
a night shift brain first of all that's
iconic that [ __ ] happens to me all the
time like i will sometimes on the toes
like i will you're like what's that girl
from um
you know scream queens called and i'll
say the name of like someone i went to
high school with i know i always get
nervous that i'm gonna do something like
that it's mortifying by the way because
then that person always reaches out and
then they think you're thinking about
them and like i'm really not
really not it just like
was in my brain you know yeah or like
worse like somebody like cyberstalk
someone whose name you shouldn't know
that's really bad this is hysterical and
not embarrassing at all and at least
it's like tarkov movies like everybody
knows him like he's top of mind he just
got engaged like he just did the gender
reveal with heather i think
oh it was a cute gender does he have any
sons yet or does he just have daughters
i don't know do they have daughters i i
as the you know target el moussa
resident historian i really should know
that and i go shopping
i know
oh my god i'm like embarrassed almost
embarrassed i need to unburden myself
now you're fine by the way that's like a
funny story and now you've got liberty
celebrity and now you got on the podcast
so the whole thing was worth it you know
yeah and now you have this inside joke
with your fellow nightmares and it's
funny and like
don't let this cloud your brain like
you're busy saving lives you know i'm
sorry like tariq al-musa the first c
lasty like it's not your fault
you just saw like that's exactly why you
had this predicament because target
almost said there can be one word there
can only be one tauric yeah no all other
tarics back down or change your last
name to amusa right i think i'm changing
my first name chao musa musa ashrae like
i'm so connected to them like i'm
obsessed you need to marry tara
claudia musa but see the thing is it's
too close to christina musa
yeah
all right ready for our third and final
yes hey jackson claude hey let's get
right to it okay my boyfriend and i have
been dating for four years and we've
lived together for almost two at this
point in our relationship we're pretty
open and comfortable with one another
farting in front of each other peeing
with the door open etc okay the other
day i was getting ready to go to work um
a work dinner with a couple of new
clients i had not yet met them in person
i was getting ready and trying on
different outfits and like greeting
myself in the mirror like pretending i
wanted to see how i would look to the
clients when they met me for the first
time i guess but i was like smiling
waving and putting my hand out for a
handshake to myself in front of the
mirror
my boyfriend walked in on me doing this
and absolutely roasted me i wasn't that
embarrassed in the moment but to be
honest i was like whatever you've seen
me do so much more embarrassing stuff
than this but thinking back on it i'm
like holy [ __ ] i'm a huge freak who
talks to themselves in the mirror and
pretends to meet new people and now my
boyfriend knows he's dating a huge freak
i keep cringing every time i think back
help me on my burden
there are cringy things that people do
in the mirror and that is not one of
them like you're a professional girl
you're taking things seriously you want
to see how every like every angle that
people are going to see you from like
what does your dress do when you put
your hand out does it go up too high
like please is does he not like he
should get his [ __ ] ass up and
network and he would know what it's like
to practice talking in the mirror you
know what i have to say
talking to yourself in the mirror
you have to be an extremely confident
person to do that because it feels weird
and most people would be like no that's
too weird i would feel like a loser and
the fact that you're able to just like
do it confidently and like actually i've
never
done that before but i actually now
might start doing that that's like a
great idea to like see how you look to
other people while you talk yeah i feel
like i've done that
i don't know in certain situations like
seeing how like okay i'm gonna practice
like smiling what kind of smile like i'm
going to the dmv what's my movie like
i don't think that's a weird thing it
takes a really confident person to do
that so like you sound beautiful
stunning and smart and your boyfriend
rosie sounds like you just have that
type of relationship like i wouldn't
take a person as long as he's not like
truly making fun of you and making you
feel bad or stupid um you did nothing
wrong and i think it's really cute and a
totally normal thing and there's like
weirder things you could do in the
mirror like dancing
do you do that not in a long time but
now that i have a house probably oh for
sure now that i have a house um i don't
have enough mirrors yet honestly like i
don't think it's that weird i feel like
i dance in the mirror all the time like
when i'm doing my makeup and i'm playing
music i look at myself and be like yeah
yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] it live your life no
you guys i could only get one life yeah
and when i started djt like i used to
talk to myself in the mirror all the
time because i was so nervous and the
only thing i could do was like
the only person i could trust was a girl
in the mirror you know
i was surrounded by a snatcher
no i'm kidding i wasn't there no i'm
kidding but like
you just like you have nowhere to turn
to so you turn to yourself almost
and i found it so immensely helpful i
still i talked to myself in the mirror
before every show so there's really
nothing wrong with it and you shouldn't
be embarrassed don't be and if he's
making you feel like
too bad about it in a nefarious way you
know what i'm saying let us know right
now
but other than that i hope we helped
everyone um they weren't that bad this
week so you guys have nothing to worry
about they're never that bad especially
once we dissected and get down to it's
always worse for the person who's
writing it in but like to fresh ears
it's like it's not that crazy yeah so
that was unburden yourselves gmail.com
coming up on wednesday we have your
toasters so that's dear toasters at
gmail.com and we're back tomorrow for
another fabulous audio and video
experience yes so hopefully we'll take
all of today's learnings and tomorrow
will be even better oh so if you're
watching on youtube because we are
working with this new camera our youtube
videos for this week will be up slightly
later it's probably gonna take about an
hour to upload and edit so um just stay
tuned they're coming every day but if
you're like so eager you can listen to
the podcast first yes so we podcasts are
up immediately we'll see you tomorrow
thank you so much for listening for the
morning toast monday morning show where
we deliver the fast fast stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as podcast
anywhere podcast can be found that's
spotify and stitcher public radio i
heart radio spots all the places within
the podcast find us totally the five
star review about a beautiful standing
smart we are hope you guys have been
crab monday incredible make it in crab
you guys see you tomorrow on
[Music]
tuesday have a great day bye